[Music]
and snacks just news
why is failing bari sax man that's not
cool submitted by gel know me
contractors working at the CIA
headquarters managed to steal three
thousand dollars in vending machine
snacks
yes oh my god hackers working at thing
say yeah huh whoa what's your favorite
chair nine oh let me Hot Cheetos flamin
hot cheetos and a fabulous and in some
vinegar yeah that's the second one
that's those are my two YouTube I really
like those kettle chips or it's like
it's borderline about to shatter your
teeth but then when you bite into it
don't mention one no you like to play I
like some vinegar I also like to salt
and pepper one I like to barbecue like
oh I like all of them is it pop the the
pop the kettle one that we get nacho one
or that I like sour the kettle the
kettle corn flavor one yeah that's my
favorite we bought a whole box of it oh
we really ran out I would say I got too
many I got
I like olive you know what I've always
hated sonship I know I don't like
sonship get the [ __ ] out of here you
[ __ ] pretty unhappy yeah that's right
me my trips that's what she start doing
to moonship oh yeah there's so many
chips that are too good but if I had to
say an OG classic I would have to go
with my sour cream and cheddar rustles
that's good ruffles that's cool that's
old-school the ridges yup if I'm talking
about the new David so I'll talk about
that kennel [ __ ] something there's a
little bit every wave in agur yes one of
my favorites from a kid when I went to
the not the Duncan no the yum yum donuts
on helium the yum yum donuts down a
sheet praying one of them to stop that
chili cheese Fritos hmm and then coke
with crushed ice yeah and then to donut
I've always wanted to try those chili
cheese Fritos and they make it into like
a kind of like a taco yeah that's called
a frito pot and with the honey barbecue
frito twist or bomb - oh yeah this was
[ __ ] good
did you guys ever like corn nuts okay
I'll still get that [ __ ] all Rohan
flavor etch is the [ __ ] nothing else is
as good hard for me so just understand
and I would just throw you love got it
and soften up in them when I was a kid I
just sucked on it and spit it out yeah
don't like corn [ __ ] ideas on like corn
and like the flavors really I'm gonna do
I smell whole back and then I got the
powdery I see yeah so now go play on the
monkey bars
after everyw says I still got some
parchment this will not the flu five
times a year no no it's probably because
your mom had you on a vegetarian diet
and you need iron or some kind of metals
in your system that's right did you read
dirt hanging on a monkey bar with their
mouth you had an iron deficiency is
probably really like craving dirt I have
a little pregnant when I did to throw
that kids Oh many ways be honest these
CIA contractors apparently they had
their vending the vending machine let's
see you being musty I like my seen
better vending lesbian I mean of things
well now me I'm not gonna seen mouth
exercises emissary I think the stupidest
to your life is Tyrion out of all the
things to steal snacks
yeah okay good yeah he paid good you
can't afford a dollar for [ __ ] chips
yeah all government contracts are good
yeah so with the way they were able to
have stupid
Murphy machine was these machines they
had they were connected via like the
internet in order to submit these
payment transactions with credit cards
and so what they did is they just unplug
the cable and I connected it to the
Internet and then they started using
unfunded cards to be able to get these
snacks out of the machine and so the CIA
realized that there was an unusual
amount of snack that were just gone
because the money didn't add up
so then what they did is they set up
cameras
is like near the vending machines and
then they found everyone that kept
cheating
I wish what they did was pull Jason
Bourne back from fighting terror yeah
and he just comes in and kicks all the
contractors at even when you work for
the CIA you still want to still or you
still want free snacks you don't pay for
that [ __ ] when you work for Experian you
still won't do that that goes to show
that the CIA don't let nobody fly you
can't get anything out of that [ __ ] yeah
- don't be so funny though if they like
do a sting operation and then when they
catch the [ __ ] they all bust out
through the doors and [ __ ] them up and
tie them down and [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
Eaters chick ha yeah don't [ __ ] chief
pilot from the government hot cheetos
crunchy or puffy both puffy for me or
aren't you launching one culture makes a
huge difference
I like follows because the pod is like
it just disintegrates in your mouth ah
satisfying all that crunch yeah
sometimes I used too much you want
mm-hmm it's good but I see it as like a
whole different thing
like once you change this it's not even
hot cheeto and eating this regular
chicken wings and extra crunchy chicken
wings yeah sometimes you want crispy
some of our thoughts you never want
something like KFC original or crunchy
ball so what is your - chicken mother
[ __ ] we had a choice would it be like
there would be all of them Kenny Casey
I'll throw up
I like crunching I like KFC churches pop
I should get on the floor I'll take it
on the block you take church's chickens
crispy chicken tenders with [ __ ]
honey and put that [ __ ] on there either
with the biscuit gets the mashed potato
so you could dip that oh yeah you get a
body like mine oh why is Fried chicken's
so delicious remember the last time a
fried chicken you thought I'd never be
given the baby fried chicken we guys
will get it for the baby bag deep exhale
she was your baby to have a big world
palate right tell me why I sit down
horny
oh man Korean fried chicken double fried
yo I make the best Korea Friday
remember what do we not know about bring
you over to this to my on dinner
welcome I mean it for Muriel and my
brother they just child all that [ __ ]
down and I marinated oh yes yes
chicken chicken Elsa sidekick I did a
mukbang on it that [ __ ] was so much yeah
tell of that when you eat in front of
the [ __ ] camera told him David Martin
went gaga
when what happened it is freaking glue
begin doing your part sugar what
happened when they got caught they take
off they got caught and I got fired no
one ever to go to jail
no one ever on them again feeling from
the kingsguard though didn't get sent to
Guantanamo Bay you're not keen you
should have got [ __ ] waterboarded
yeah wow you guys are curious to see
what feels like you don't want a
boarding I could do never get it before
no you don't want to do anything it's
[ __ ] crazy not it I haven't done it
it's [ __ ] crazy trying waterboard
yourself I tried to try to my dream
myself you know on so period with a
washcloth and the [ __ ] basket
literally feels like you're drowning me
yeah well you can't India why don't you
do everyone what talk to God or right
didn't like everyone the people so when
you when you see it in the movie SES but
if I was a booking towel on his face and
there's water but because the water it
covers I'm in the towel covers your nose
and your mouth full as soon as you pour
water the water it turns into like this
vacuum and it goes pitch like seriously
like a saran wrap and the water just
keeps going it literally feels like
you're drowning Wow it's [ __ ] crazy
as a cop out on myself I'll always be
the Chinese drip torture does that what
I don't know [ __ ] on yeah you want I
want to feel like what aboard you're
doing lunchtime sure I've always wanted
to know what it felt like how do you get
so annoyed by a jungle water never had
water just drop on your face out of
nowhere it's [ __ ] annoying
I think the key element for like three
four hours straight you'll get annoyed
if someone's like hey hey hey hey hey
stop it actually is Mike repetitive
something yeah
oh really Doggett I like crazy fire
alarms hey hey Carlos
okay okay okay once again hey hey hey
doctor the fine
hey hey hey come on huh what if I could
just a loud noise like in Dumb and
Dumber I think your brains out in the
world throat hurts now that wasn't
wasn't I want to do trying to like be
mentally stronger than anything annoying
so like if I was stuck in a room and
their friends in there clean even spit
it like ten minutes where is the most
annoying I'm not annoyed I'm just moving
Church there's a difference there's a
difference between being still and
annoyed being still an annoyance
I wasn't annoyed I just can't stay still
but there's a difference because if
someone's in like so one is this imagine
a stinky breath [ __ ] with
alcohol and cigarette breath and you in
your face like this and he's talking to
you really loud that's annoying
yes but then the other one is just like
being fidgety like I'm my mind occupy
but my body feels like you're like oh I
understand but I'd fall asleep in those
situations
aha sermons more room oh man I used to
ask for some of the Catholic churches in
a little and I was just sitting with
using side fascist forces yeah I didn't
sit still either the lady behind me
[ __ ] hated me
that's why I go to church you've got to
be a good speaker because I can't be
sitting there with those dry eyes
[ __ ] today we're going to be
all gone go to that temple that [ __ ] is
it's just so calm it'll really painting
I mean a good preacher you got to speak
to my soul not to my ears
well going back on this next step thing
is you're such a food stand everyone
here and you gather food fans what would
you guys do if you found out that
someone was feeling positive [ __ ] chop
off their [ __ ] hands you could steal
money from me but once you start
stealing
snacks it's personal yeah can you read
for to eating the leftover again and
then you come home it's gone yeah that's
pure Ranger [ __ ] pit yeah and took
their leftovers I will not name this
person oh um but yet I don't mind if
they eat my [ __ ] I don't care just
[ __ ] replaces ya or ask me person I
don't even care you rent that me [ __ ]
you finish it what can replace you know
our friend brother was really weird he
loved he loved leftover so much that his
mom would be like uh hey we're going to
go to JJ cafe were just down the street
do you want anything goes not for today
but can you get me a chicken chow mein
and it's put in the refrigerator
sometimes I knew that he loved that
thing for the DJ he loves it he loves
leftover so much he doesn't want to eat
the crispy noodles fresh he wanted to be
refrigerated and then take it out and
then put into microwave and then you'll
eat it I kind of feel get that because
that time with curry
I feel like Curry's better the next day
never that they would have original yeah
the chow mein yeah it's like a gumbo you
make it the day before any service yeah
combo oh so do I but when it comes to
food that should be fresh like Mexican
food yeah Mexican food is never good as
leftovers
I like day-old subway never I will never
eat a Subway sandwich day-old it is
disgusting like Subway the way it is
this is all got the nastiest thing ever
I love it
you mean like when you get up and then
the whole thing is saga [ __ ] book that's
gross because I you know the thing is
I've never liked hard bread like I guess
there's my mouth don't like it yeah I
never took my bread on it I said I don't
like like hard crunchy stuff and usually
I don't like eating anything cookies too
because I like it so hard I could smack
somebody over the head and make it white
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]